des cris d'amour c'est très chiant tpe
chaque chroniqueur papa de tous les
crédits comme ce qu'on va pas faire non
plus deux heures les défis de l'amour
mais certains chroniqueurs vont jouer
avec un défi et j'en ferai également
je vous le dis pour faire gagner un
magnifique cadeau à quelqu'un qui est au
téléphone
d'accord d'accord merci rimont juges tu
vas voir pas plus on pourra les médias
pour toi ça va être très simple
franchement c'est plutôt simple tu vas
avoir une minute pour trouver une
personne et danser avec elle sur un
poteau mais de façon très sexy ah oui un
poteau dans leur rue ok ok on peut
travailler vous toujours
[Applaudissements]
côté
j'adore si beaucoup c'est très simple tu
vas voir une minute pour trouver une
personne en voitures allait lui offrir
des fleurs et demander un petit bisou en
retour enfin c'est quoi la limite tu vas
jouer pour un casque de réalité
virtuelle
j'ai pas de fils et ma foi oui bah tu en
voilà
et donc j'arrête une voiture n'importe
qui non non non
[Applaudissements]
alors n'ayez pas de voitures attendent
sa voiture avait l'habitude de les
placer un bon jour mardi m arrêt à sa
cause en bus
c'est reposant c'est pourtant à messi ne
la regardait patented il a fallu sortir
iphone voilà un cousin
[Applaudissements]
le bisou j'étais gagner un cousin
valérie c'est très simple vous allez
devoir partir ouais ah bon vous allez
avoir exactement à moi pour trouver donc
[Rires]
ce gars là bas les intentions de
toujours mal au bras chéri ouais les
eaux tranquilles dakar chine tranquille
alors valérie tu vas voir une minute tu
vas jouer on va jouer pour une machine à
café bar machine à café laquelle tu vas
voir humide pour aller faire une
déclaration d'amour à un inconnu
pourquoi quelqu'un pour patrick je suis
sur les chars attention phénomène n'a
pas de fonds non l'on reconnaît non non
il était dit que le fait n'est pas le
messie est là attention faccio tu me
fais peur sur la route comme la voilà la
regarde la connais ta soeur je voulais
simplement le moulin adversaire je vous
ai vus régulièrement fils de céline
studio il est beau gosse est en fait
assez recèlent bien voyez je me disais
que ben vous aviez vraiment la tête du
compteur de charme que il est beau gosse
que le plus beau des couscous est
vraiment vous étiez voilà une petite
boulette neiges je voulais faire partie
à votre tour vous étiez un mois les
caméras dans cette déclaration parce que
vous êtes sous le charme
propose l'air chaud cyril c'est vrai ce
que je fais ce que je peux rattraper la
métaphore avec un stylo un seul outil
serait allé ouais
[Applaudissements]
on attend les papas du 3 mai à toi ben
ali m'a tapé chaud dans l'émission c'est
très simple vous allez avoir
vous avez joué avec maxime gagny pour
une console de jeu portable ou là tu vas
voir une minute pour trouver une
personne lui demander son prénom et le
crier de plaisir comme si vous faisiez
l'amour avec lui well accorsi d'accord
voulais faire c'est madame web russe
puisse vous demander votre prénom à la
laïcité
marie cécile et ceci au mieux mon cas la
mia marais cccc je t'aime d'accord
darfour d'amour contador et evans qui
l'a qui sera dans l'instant présent
il a refait il faut faire quoi mais
quand tu te faisais l'amour c'est comme
si tu ne connais pas au fessier la haute
a pas demandé de chanter
marie-cécile mais vient je ne les oublie
mutine tueur est dehors pour l'instant
ça n'est pas gagné
on ne sait pas satisfaisant mais
peut-être que c'est lui reste dehors
mais sert fera des orgasmes jusqu'à la
fin de l'émission nord a tout de même
voté contre dallas stars